when you first started out how much did
you want to be an aess actor oh uh yeah
I think as much as I understood it I
wanted it you know uh I wanted to do
everything and uh my idea of that has
expanded with experience you know uh and
age but at the time I meant that I
wanted to do action movies and I want to
do drama movies and I want to do comedy
movies I want to be able to be Michael J
fox but also Tom Cruz I wanted all these
things all want you know um and now I
realize that it's oh so much more than
that like there's so many aspects to
this world and this career um but uh
yeah I wanted to be all of it and uh
that was the dream right that that's the
only thing that I could really
understand is being the movie star who
gets to you
know be Iron Man you know and then take
a break and then make another movie but
I feel like what I I like more what I
feel about it now right uh I love the
idea of getting to do all different
genres all different experiences I love
uh getting to I'm going and doing a play
uh an equity show in a couple of months
you know and I haven't gotten to do a
play since before covid so that's really
exciting where I'm directing a movie
right now and then I finish the edit and
I'll go straight into acting in uh this
play
uh with professional actors on location
and then I'll come back here and then
worry about the next job but like doing
it all and being able to hopefully drop
into those roles whether it's the lead
role in a play or it's um a supporting
role you know uh on a TV show or
something like that I I love all of that
and the idea of continually working in
one aspect or another is very exciting
to me and I feel like there's so much
that you can do and if you're like so
far this year it it's just this great
feeling for me of like I'm busy doing
exclusively stuff I'm excited about
right like you know getting to I wrote a
movie earlier this year and that movie
came out in April a movie called pretty
Stoned on MTV and that was like a stoner
comedy right and I was working on that
all through the holidays and whatnot
finished that that thing happened then I
dropped into directing uh Miss Valentine
which was amazing and now I'm in post on
that and then I'll drop out of that and
I'll go do misery you know um at this
theater called stage Center in Louisiana
and then hopefully the second half of
the year is exciting as the first half
of the year but that's it I mean to me
that's a list like what do you want to
do you know what are your options you
know I can direct this or I can write
this um all right I'm going to try to do
both because that's usually the guy that
I am um and then somebody will be mad
because they have to wait but it's all
going to be okay but yeah that that's
the new dream it's like I wouldn't
betrayed what my 15-year-old self
thought was the dream right now for
anything
like I don't want it you know it doesn't
sound attractive to me you know I mean
good for Brad Pit good for Tom Cruz good
for all those things by the way people
aren't exactly banging down the door for
me to be the next Brad Pit I don't
understand why but they're not uh but
that was a joke I'm just
kidding but you know it's like that's
great but it's not my dream anymore you
know my my dream is uh just to be able
to do anything that I really get excited
about and uh and to have a very
Renaissance kind of artistic experience
sure I think when you're younger I I
used to look at Brook Shields and just
want to be her so so you know when
you're younger you think you want all
that and maybe you do but that's also
not an easy path there's also other
things that happen and now with
influencers people can also want that
and I guess my my take from all that is
it sounds like you're living the artist
lifestyle so always keeping busy it's a
lifestyle it's not this like destination
yeah yeah and I think that that's super
important when you're starting out and
when you're looking at it is that if you
want fame and fortune you know um this
is a
very difficult and upsetting path for
you because the things that have given
me the most legitimacy you know I
wouldn't even say Fame but the most um
the stronghold of like this is the movie
that you may have seen That's my movie I
made that movie and that leads you to
something else right uh but there was no
fortune right the the fortune doesn't
really come with the things you think
it's going to come with it comes with
the the things that are just like well
that'll be fun and then you know I did
the voice of Peter Pan for Disney and
made more money on that than I have in
any of my films together right
from doing you know a voice over uh
which I love and which is super cool and
one of my favorite things to do uh I
still get to do it um and I'll do it as
long as they allow me to because Peter
Pan I mean that's a great part um but
it's not you know my heart it's not the
work that I you know uh Blood Sweat and
tear you know create um it's just this
fun thing that I do and that pays more
money than usually most of these other
things but that you have to embrace that
or you're going to be very unhappy
because the the disappointment in the
financial side and the fame side and the
you know why an ey on People magazine or
whatever it's like you can't make those
dominoes fall you know you can only do
the best job that you can do and then
let the work exist for itself and if
you're okay with that if you're living
this artist kind of ideal of like my
point is I just want as many people to
see six-month rule as humanly possible
right and a bunch of people have seen it
you know I was on Showtime for a long
time it's like it didn't make me a
household name but that wasn't the goal
the goal was for six-month rule to be a
movie that I was proud of and it is um
but I think if you compartmentalize it
it's doable to live like that if you go
big and you're comparing yourself to
every actor or director or writer who's
doing better than you and you're like
well why are they making this money or
why are they in on succession you know
why aren't I doing this then it's just
it's just too much you know I think it
uh it can break people you know can we
talk about the challenges of working as
an actor but not maybe a list MH sure
well I mean it's it's great uh I really
like it I really like acting I like
acting and stuff that I direct which
some people think is very weird but like
I enjoy it um it's uh it's always a
thing right so like I don't know I I
guess what's weird now is that well let
me go back it does seem in this business
that people really want to see you as
one thing right people are very
reluctant to embrace you know a
multi-hyphenate kind of person even
though as you've said earlier that is
what's making so many people amazingly
successful right but if you're a writer
then they want you just to write don't
let maybe don't direct just just write
this one and we'll get a real director
or if they know you as a director
they'll be like well maybe don't mess
around with the script too much you know
like and you know if they know you with
an actor then they certainly don't want
you directing or writing anything unless
you've given up on acting completely
like that's something that people are
comfortable with it's like I used to act
and now I do this it's like well I do it
all and usually I bump into people who
have a problem with one or all of it I
don't know why it's a thing but um but
yeah I've acted longer than I've done
either of the other two things
successfully you know like built a
career been able to you know uh afford a
life and blah blah blah but if they know
you as the other thing they're very
reluctant to have you do this thing and
um it's it always that's the most
frustrating things to me is that um you
know you have a resume you have a real
you have an IMDb number you have all of
these things you know but also it comes
with the caveat of but you know he's a
director or he's a writer then it's like
okay well we're going to get a real
actor to do this part and I'm like
you're killing me right now that's
frustrating to me I don't like losing
out on parts to people who are
less famous than I am and you I really
just narrow it down to fame it's like
less experience that's fine you know if
they're better great but so much of
casting this business I've had to deal
with a lot of the people look at what
their IMDb numbers are how many
followers they have yada y yada and then
they make decisions based on that like
exclusively I've seen and I'm I don't
like that I think it should all come
together but my biggest thing has always
been when I'm directing something I'm
like I'm going to play this part unless
we get somebody who brings more to the
table right and that normally means Fame
legitimacy followers you know star meter
or something like that um so I don't
like that it's a steeper hill now than
it should be right like it's sometimes I
feel like it's a steeper Hill for me
than it is for the producer's best
friend who's a struggling actor because
that's an easy get but if I do it then I
become a liability on the project or
something I don't like that but it is a
thing that comes up a lot um and you
know I I feel like you know agents and
casting director everybody's got their
things I have casting directors that
love me that call me in and I'm very
thankful that they remember my name name
and my number and whatnot and I have
other people that won't call me in
because I've cast their actors and stuff
before and they think of me as a
director and that's it um so I don't
know I don't like doors being closed in
my face because I try to do all these
different roles um I mean I don't I
don't mind if you don't like what I do
of course I mind but um but I understand
but like this whole idea of like I can't
be as good at this as I am at this is
stupid and it annoys me in IMDb star
meters and social media can be
manipulated too oh sure I mean it's all
scam it's all a scam we've just decided
that that's the [__] that we're
going to embrace right everybody knows
that the IMDb store meter is some
algorithm that makes no sense and nobody
knows how it comes about but yes but we
also know that that's exactly what the
casting director and the producer and
the executive producer and the director
look at that's the number we've just
decided to pretend that we don't know
that it's complete Malarkey and you know
just based on some silly algorithm you
know or or a project you just did and so
everyone's searching it and then all of
a sudden you're you're up to at the top
so absolutely you know there wasn't too
long ago where uh we were looking at an
actor and their star meter was really
high and we were excited about it we
found out later it was because of
something uh like he gotten pulled over
for a DUI or something like that and he
was in the newes oh no and it was like
oh well that's useless well it's all
based on nothing but I mean most of it's
based on nothing you know what I mean
most of it's just like uh what is
Matthew saying that Wolf of Wall Street
it's uh fugazi fugazi it's fairy dust
you know none of it means anything but
we've all kind of decided that with
nothing else to guide us we're going to
look at IMDb and look at those
numbers I don't know why what has this
industry taught you about
fame
um changes fast like Fame changes people
really quickly and I you know not
necessarily for the bad but it
definitely changes people's lives like
I've I've just known too many actors you
know who have gone from uh you know
struggling to regulars on TV shows you
know movie stars whatever and it's a lot
of pressure um I think it it's difficult
for them it's also difficult for those
that care about them you know um
Fame the The Stereotype which I think is
that for a reason is that you know once
somebody um has enough income to have a
lawyer and a manager and an agent and
you know uh all of that a publicist all
of the legitimizing factors
there that then those people start
trying to control you and making sure
that you don't blow this gravy train
that you're on and that they're on um so
people get very very timid very quickly
but
also so for instance if like I had
written a part for you and then uh all
of a sudden you became incredibly famous
and I suddenly had the ability to put
the movie together your people would be
very reticent about doing that movie but
that's fair because also people come out
of the you know woodwork looking to
benefit from you in some way and if
you're listening to your reps what
they're probably saying is you can do so
many things to screw this up literally
nine out of the 10 things you can do
will ruin this ride that you're on so we
have to really think and decide what
that one that tenth thing is and that's
the thing that we have to do I don't
know if that's necessarily true just
being from the independent film world I
see you know movies people are in good
movies people are in bad movies people
are in fantastic movies people are in
terrible movies and most of those you
never even hear about you know like
you'll be in a fantastic movie that wins
South by Southwest and it never gets a
release you know um I've seen that
happen and I've seen you know uh people
who are famous newly famous or whatever
do something for their budy in a movie
that again disappears right and or when
Sundance right this is just the nature
of it I think you got to stick with your
gut and try not to let those things
affect you but I don't know that you can
it's too much it's too much the the fame
that like a TV show gets you and I I
feel like oddly TV show is a better
example than movies because you can you
know be doing movies for years and
you're technically a movie star but like
you know my aunt doesn't know who you
are you know or my uh kid cousin right
when my aunt and my kid cousin know who
you are your life is crazy like that's a
crazy life you know um and I think TV is
still the number one access point for
those people I don't know if it will be
for long I feel like you know the the
streaming world is changing things so
quickly but still right now whatever the
number one show on CBS is those people
are known worldwide you know Blue Bloods
or something like that you know it's
like I've never seen an episode but
people know people know all over the
world and uh and how could it not change
people it's challenging but it's also
just uh it's also just fairy dust you
know it's not really real but
unfortunately
or fortunately that is kind of the um
the tender in this business is that we
independent film I try to get the most
famous face most successful uh
recognizable talented person I can get
um for the least amount of money so that
I can put them on a poster and I can
legitimize this movie before you even
see it that's the idea in independent
film is that you try to build a poster
that somebody will by right even if the
movie's terrible and then you go and try
to make an amazing great movie right but
my life is about I have to sell these
movies these movies have to sell or I am
no longer you know worthy of my position
right if I make the greatest movie that
nobody wants to see that's useless I
have to make something that um is
exciting to buyers is exciting to
audiences and then I get to make it
again right um but also there's the idea
of making the best thing you possibly
can the good thing is often times these
faces these uh names that we want to use
are incredibly talented people you know
like we we did a a Valentine's movie a
couple years ago with Richard kind
Richard kind is an amazing actor right
he's also the name that they agreed on
the producers agreed on that I was like
yes him right because you go through the
dance and you can imagine there are
names and people that I'm like no no no
this if I can find somebody that's Uber
talented and also satisfies that idea
for them of of a face or a name that
brings import to the project uh then
that's the the gold
standard